here's what you have to understand 300
episodes is a landmark in the television
world a major milestone and now NCIS
joins the ranks of CSI Law & Order and
ER
so with tremendous heartfelt gratitude
to all of you I say happy 300th episode
why did NCIS make it to 300
kick it right back to this group of
people you know I'd work hard every day
they like coming to work we like each
other nothing wrong with loving your job
and there's a lot to love here as usual
Michael may be all fun and games right
now but he will miss this place and his
cast mates will definitely miss him
are you serious I'll miss him so much
everyone will miss him it's been a huge
huge catifying awesome experience and
when I'm in my old folks rest home which
is only a few years from now I will look
back on these 300 episodes and I think
I'm I'm really most impressed with the
audience that found this show and the
fans out all around the world that love
these characters and I think that's if
anything that's what kept this show
going